le retour de ces norway ya de monde
c'est ce que les gens se retrouvent sur
scène d'orgie haribo alors c'est qu'une
bêta c'est page officielle le jeu
officiel sur je crois le 26 mars
en tout cas tarder game je voulais juste
voit à quoi ça ressemble on va se faire
une partie sur le stand or le plus beau
de tous les temps juste regardez-moi ça
c'est un truc de malade
c'est vraiment plus le petit jeu steiner
gratuit qu'on connaît alors juste le
point info la bêta vous pouvez y accéder
donc le doigté dans les discussions pour
ceux qui veulent accéder c'est payant en
fait au juste précommandé le jeu je
crois qu'il faut 6 euros et vous aurez
accès à la bêta et vous recevrez une
copie du jeu le jour où il sort voilà
alors comme d'hab vous trouvez des on en
a déjà
c'est une page dans le club henri texte
viole donc ne regarde pas où il va
devoir
bon on s'en fout oui oh [ __ ] alors
c'est parti on va continuer je marche
dans la forêt d'art mollahs 3 ok donc
voilà ça c'est fait d'accord donc j'ai
joué ce matin très vite fait d'ailleurs
un gros merci à orione pour me l'avoir
payé parce que ma carte je pêche des
jeux sur internet bref
gros bisous à toi marie et et puis voilà
c'est parti on se plonge dans l'horreur
ce jeu oblige ici un hommage posthume
par sur une page 6 bon c'est pas des
contenaires comme ça
garder tout ça bon mot au bon ça ça veut
dire qu'à cette heure mon avis voilà
doit continuer de tonneaux ces
conteneurs moi j'aime la reine a tranché
nage [ __ ] de merde elle j'ai trop peur
de le voir je n'ai jamais vu encore
alors à quand une honda monte tout
doucement vers le pot propos alors est
ce que les règles restent les mêmes que
dans le christ numbers à savoir que
quand tu cours ils tous repères plus
vite comme ça
[ __ ] c'est une page là bas walla walla
walla walla walla au [ __ ]
ok ok ok ok ok ok pas quelqu'un que je
vois plus large au point peut plus rien
je fais quoi jeu halo ok c'est bon ok je
peux je me dirige wap hutin s'appuie
super en fait que l'image et le saute ça
fait sursauter au hockey après j'ai lu
version saut incroyable
ouah mickaël pagis hippie tard mais
c'est obligé
en fait peut-être que je coure trop
voilà mon avis je cours trop du coup il
me repère tas de 84,4 ok on va monter
samia des brochets on peut pas aller
là-haut waouh oui vite ou pas sauter bon
jeu paraît qu'on peut pas les trouver un
obata non je me casse c'est bon c'est
bon c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon c'est
vache à lait corps cours quoi les
ampoules et là-bas baisse
on se rattrape le au hockey non c'est un
endroit que je ne connais pas en plus de
toi là ok donc on peut pas mourir
ça serait cool parce que ça n'est pas
bon pas bon je m'en vais je m'en vais
demander
désolé pour la qualité de la vidéo en
passant ses webcams j'ai plus de
batterie le canon et là j'avais trop
envie de faire cette vidéo art c'est
parti c'est un espèce de chrome 2
décroche vous le stress la fatigue et le
stress bardel reste cailloux là il me
stresse bordel il continue en
continuelle ça commençait méga stressant
d'être là
là je sens qu'il va vous ne jamais se
retourner dans ce teaser oui pardon
pardon pardon pardon continue dont les
armes voiture oh oui base y aller deux
endroits de voiture pas dans la voiture
oui j aime feuilles oui on se casse
on se marre gâchis oui parfait entre les
deux arbres est les champions ou tu
continues tu as cours ce jusqu'à la tour
de rigaud et we go à l'est plus c'est un
verbe l'a obligé ou volontaire non
moi j'étais sonné y'a pas une [ __ ] de
pages ici waouh
ok c'est le rap us la plus achevée je
m'en vais je m'en vais merde
une barrière là-bas la lumière des
lumières alzheimer elle avait su allumer
emballage alors pardon pardon pardon
attendu une voie non aux bâtards
toi tu es en train de contourner comme
un gros porc oh [ __ ] de merde en 560
les cailloux j'aime provoquer mais face
aux cailloux elle est continu continu
continu
j'aime marcher sur les [ __ ] marche
pas ils vous tre au [ __ ] je criais
[ __ ] merde en plus c'est trop trop de
trucs trop près pour voir l'autre je
dois faire clic droit mais après tu vois
tu voyais que dalle en fait autant et
c'est en grand bond continu-continu
montrent ces procédés à la papa devant
moi comme ça par magie c'est un peu un
possible au plus tard mais j'ai aucune
idée d'où je vais faire mais quand tu
connais pas la map c'est waou super
chaud on fait des aveux en fait je sais
pas m'en foncé
dire y'a un grillage va passer ici au rc
pour au pardon ok ok je ne joue plus
premier juste que je me fais c'est bon
c'est bon non plus merci monsieur k you
[ __ ] mais c'est pas possible mais il a
bien dit eh bien j'ai coincé deux pages
la annaba williams passe là-bas au
[ __ ] thunder tu vas arrêter de me
casser les couilles haye continue
continue à les font certains j'ai vu la
lumière de dieu se met sur la paix pour
la tournée de quatre allez on continue
au [ __ ] si je le finis oh la la la
vache à lait marche tranquillement
non non pas du palais j'ai vu ses gants
tager mussig mme nasty
or le voit à peine 9 heures
là-bas a battu mort à laifour son sens
son slogan put en plus je suis sûr
qu'ils vont sortir plein de maps et ou
quand le jeu il sera vraiment sorti ça
va être trop bien allez on y va
hawx hyde park informations sentent bon
jour
ole pas tard les brutes ya au [ __ ] la
vache au [ __ ]
donc on s'enfonce la merde
non non il va arriver arrive et les
cheveux sans fin
merde oh merde place à la touche par
hans demant
et si je me lave les mains c'est un
super moment pour se laver les mains
super jusqu'avant la bouche en passons
des toilettes gloire des toilettes un
couloir toilettes couloir on va aller
aux toilettes
enfin tous
c'est franchement il est pire et [ __ ]
le jeu pas comme on peut si elle a du
mal à suivre
ils m'ont tellement de ressources mais
demain c'est juste incroyable yens page
ici plus tard pour la trouver et des
sapins et tout à la sorte
non mais c'est pas possible a forcément
une page ici bordel toile alors oubliez
moi ou elle est la page up mais c'est
pas possible ça y est c'est obligatoire
quai
alors y at il un sdf ici je répète sdf
yat il montrait bien ça bien je m'en
vais après deux phases
oh là là ils mettent des vues reflet on
dirait vraiment qu'il ya un mec obtint
un rapt a ajouté une page suis truc là
non mais c'est pas possible
mais a forcément une page là dedans fin
opus a trop rester système d'heures il
va sera menée là ça sent pas bon ça sent
la fin des beaux jours
voilà [ __ ] mais ça fait trop facile
qu'il avait dans un couloir comme ça bon
allez on continue c'est quoi am en fait
ce n'est pas du mec ok d'accord alors
fait le mec a mis des claquettes à en
devenir
il s'est dit ça comme ça j'ai fermé gars
du bout ici à des toilettes comme
parrain pops à fait plat le bruit stop
aussi bien forcément non plus sans
bandage forcément une page qui partait
de la peine mais non merde hôpital s est
donné à tous de quoi bon c'est mon
échappée au match un peu arrête toi on a
échappé la voilà c'est mon métier
toi les fautes en vain mot page a
maintenant c'est juste le on n'a pas le
choix les gens faut aller là dedans au
maire mais j'ai pas envie on va partir à
la chasse sanglier c'est le trop bon
moment pour aller à la chasse au
sanglier j'ai pas tué viager est
désormais on va remonter voir tourner au
nord-ouest est obligé qui en a fait une
grosse part on va aller chercher
ailleurs
on n'est pas allé ce petit chemin je
crois qui mène au chaos cargo à la
voiture tu as la boîte chose quand même
la plus dure à trouver un bon façon et
du groupe où sont les août dernier le
boulot
des fait poisser la doc est donc là on a
les cargos là où on a lumière très bien
on va retourner on va sans réalité vers
le début à savoir là on a commencé à
jouer
[ __ ] j'ai envie de spa j'ai envie
d'écouter
ban à n'importe quel truc je préférais
le faire que plus douce vers sa joie je
prends acte et du one direction hockey
omega
moi
direction la voiture aux caisses à la
borne y aller on a fait tourner là bas
vers la bas allaient ses coutures on
peut pas la passer à la petite maison
dans la prairie pour passe dans les
herbes hautes de trucs à peine bloc
matériel se passe
la salle des fêtes du mon ami
où es tu c'est bon c'est bon ce qui est
génial c'est qu'on s'habitue et qu'après
on a moins en moins peur c'est plutôt
cool
[ __ ] range de merde temps mais ici on
voit rien mais regardez quoi
ou google go go go go waouh frappe ce
qu'il fait des siennes roucou ralenti
pièce en pièce
non j'ai pas que la page pour que la
prochaine à toi la toile à toi je te
donne la tâche sera beaucoup appris
[ __ ] de merveilles sur le fini voila
voila j'ai tout excité
plus que dans un film de cul
non elle est là bas du visage monsieur
blanc j'ai bien reçu blanche d'hôpital
un bateau est forcément une voiture ce
bateau
on est sur on est dans un schéma est sur
la bonne voie là
plus trash et
j'en ai à [ __ ] des cargos
pas
[ __ ] de chemin que des cargos de merde
c'est pas possible
d'ailleurs il y avait de lourdes à lui
on a l'eau chaude dans les chiottes
yaffa vous allez sûrement
souplet les chiottes je demande please
oui ça
r2
oui ah oui parfait allez on y va pardon
le rocher car voilà
j'ai du pardon l'arbre ah non j'ai pas
dû
les gens on n'a pas le choix
on aa les phares sur un spectre allez
hop c'est parti si vous la voyez en plus
en regardant la vidéo est pas moi ta
tante je suis ni un seul enders et quand
ou celle qui nous
ah ouais là mais je vais je vais car
[ __ ] c'est toucher américain
jusqu'à rapide
avec ap
la dent dans la baignoire
non
marie
la table
elle est allée va sera menée l'autre là
ici là
ta par contre j'ai à passer de fond de
recul on se retrouve vite cologne reste
assez
pas tout faire
en fait c'est un gros piège chez
toilettes
ge dans un piège sais tu vas venir on va
mourir non non non c'est pas pouces vous
êtes sérieux là
dans ce parking
les mémoires est il est pas là où aucun
toilettes d'accord
j'en rêve
par ailleurs la
sakho affaire touche pas tu moyabi ya
forcément un chemin qui n'est pas rien
là-bas tabac il ya la voiture
tu as les alouettes on sait qu'on va
retrouver leurs actions
on vient [ __ ] merde serait un plus
l'homme et sur l'absence d'orientation
côté on a obligé m pages ici
à
baba
[Applaudissements]
dans le groupe 2
[ __ ] de quoi bon nul effet
il est au taquet mais dégage dégage de
neige
dans le monde
la terre
je prétends bourré pour dr
lucho au nom en merde
jamal temps de la vidéo alors c'est
parti
hu
faut pas partir à la neige s'il vous
plaît non bonjour merde devient le joker
m on n'est pas tranquille dans les
banlieues
moi je la bats
avec
continue
danse espèce de truc qui monte mais
jamais d'arrière bordel
manque 2 pages on aghanim d'un jamais
fait de ma vie aussi longue sur standard
d'ailleurs un endroit que je vois ça
paie ou dans les boîtes aux lettres ya
deux pages notoriété sais pas
normal et juste
en tant que la lumière ne guide jeu
oh [ __ ] ok ok je suis sûr que theolia
center for health center de merde
le pouvoir des chartes gamoniac je vais
là où y'avait cela nord est
voilà vers ici tout à fait
tout à fait j'aime bien on assiste
effectivement un joli marathon en pleine
nuit à 4h du mat avec un homme blanc qui
te courent après alors marcel quelles
sont tes impressions actuellement sur le
jeu ont peut-être de merde en direct de
la forêt je peux te dire que c'est très
people gros vasque naïve que j'ai trouvé
un nouveau show men qui va sûrement me
mener à la page qui me va
et qu'a fait c'est la voiture de tout à
leur succès
l'industrie que ce qu'elle doit beaucoup
appris
mais c'est pas
non mais franchement mais l'année que je
marque bouafia je comprends pas où celle
ci
c'est impossible
page part de tous tout les jeunes sont
des toilettes et
à l'instar
faye
j'ai ressenti bon moi je parle pas de ce
pressentiment la laisse moi
vous allez deux doigts snelders
pressentiment et les plus importants
entre les cailloux l'aï pas regardé
[ __ ]
ah bon
je [ __ ] de merde
bon on est entrain de chances d'une
prochaine vidéo chat au monde pis
[Musique]
m